[Musique]
elle a rené-corail bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la coordinatrice du festival
alimenterre qui se déroule jusqu'au 30
octobre et qui fait des arts déjà en
france ces dix ans mais en martinique
c'est la quatrième édition c'est bien ça
oui c'est bien ça donc l'objectif avant
l'objectif on va parler de tout club de
l'objectif alimentaire alimentaire qui
s'écrie t comme la terre quoi lima avec
la terre alors c'est quoi l'objectif de
ce festival
alors l'objectif global du festival
c'est de
c'est une sensibilisation et de faire
prendre conscience aux citoyens de la
nécessité de réconcilier la nature
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
c'est le message qu'on essaye de faire
passer d'accord vous allez donc jeter
des films documentaires sur les dangers
de la de la malbouffe de la
surproduction de l'agriculture intensive
de lutte ici de l'utilisation des
pesticides c'est bien ça combien de
films alors cette année il y a huit
films pour pour débattre autour de
tester différentes thématiques et l
enfant fait l'objectif c'est de dire
qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir un corps
sain dans un esprit celle il faut aussi
une alimentation saine voilà en gros
c'est ça c'est l'alimentation
on le voit un peu partout elle
l essentiel est le
elle nous permet justement la bonne
santé de rester en bonne santé et en
voile par la quantité de cancer qui peut
y avoir un peu en martinique notamment
est partout en france et dans le monde
les conséquences de cette malbouffe de
cette mauvaise alimentation
voile et puis de l'utilisation des
pesticides aussi de l'agriculture oui on
peut aussi l'utilisation des pesticides
est un élément
important dans cette situation est on
le thème de cette édition c'est notre
avenir notre avenir se trouve dans notre
assiette
quels sont les enjeux selon vous alors
il ya différents enjeux alors on
on permet d'enfin on nous amène à
réfléchir sur la nécessité de penser
global et agir local
donc c'est dans nos différents actions
comment enfin on essaie de voir comment
à notre échelle on peut bien on peut
changer les choses on peut
[Musique]
on peut agir différemment consommer
différemment pour arriver à des
résultats différents quoi est-ce que
vous qu'à travers ça vous êtes en train
de dire que qu'il faut éviter de de se
fournir toujours dans les mêmes circuits
et je pense surtout à la grande
distribution de réduire voilà c'est
directement aller directement au
producteur c'est ça la voilà donc on
encourage les gens à avoir ce qu'on peut
appeler un fermier ou
un paysan de famille chez qui il sert il
il est le se fournit pour avoir ces
aliments ou à pratiquer son appel
l'aviculture aubaine ou l'agriculture de
famille ou le jardin ce qu'on appelle
aussi le jardin l'agriculture urbaine
bien ces phénomènes
bien qu'ils aient grandi sans ces
dernières années
dans les grandes villes e
montréal toronto notamment au canada où
j'étais donc je peux en parler un peu au
pied des cités sur les balcons partout
on peut avoir un petit espace un petit
lopin de terre en produits ont produit
même dans des pays où le climat ne le
permet pas chaque fois que c'est
possible
ils produisent des aliments
pour leur consommation voilà est-ce que
à terme c'est aussi aboutir à
l'autosuffisance alimentaire
alors on parle d'auto suffisance mais en
enfin jusqu'ici
on ne sait pas encore quelque chose qui
est réellement possible donc peut-être à
fortiori à en finalité ce ça peut être
ça mais on parle pas encore
d'autosuffisance alimentaire lorsqu'on
fait six jardins les jardins où ces
méthodes d'agriculture au bénin c'est à
dire que vous prenez quoi vous prenez
une consommation sobre comme comme le
dit pierre rabhi une sobriété heureuse
c'est ça c'est à dire que l'on consomme
ce que l'on a besoin pas plus oui voilà
donc cesser le gaspillage pas de
gaspillage justement donc c'est une des
thématiques du festival également on
parle du gaspillage alimentaire de tous
les effets que ça peut avoir sur la
planète et
et de tous les
les voilà tous les phénomènes que sacré
un peu un peu partout alors huit films
sont projetés seront projetés jusqu'au
c'est ça jusqu'au 30 novembre
[Musique]
vous avez déjà commencé mardi c'était le
film la projection du film bugs
d'andreas johnsen
o la médiathèque de certains sur cet
esprit tout à fait et vous avez aussi
proposé de la dégustation d'insectes
après le film déjà on va parler du film
bugs ses films c'est qu'ils proposent
voyage culinaire mes voyages culinaires
être assez spécial quand même c'est un
voyage culinaire de
deux scientifiques en fait qu'ils sont
c'est ce sont des cuisiniers en fait
donc c'est une expérience gustative
donc ils passent à travers les cinq
continents pour pour un petit peu
expérimenté les pratiques
d'anthropophagie des des peuples le
peuple un génial d'accord est ce que est
ce que aujourd'hui donc aaa après ce
film après la projection donc une
dégustation des sectes comment les gens
ont réagi
alors ben on leur a proposé des grillons
des vers de farine assaisonnée à
différentes sauce au curry et tout ça et
ben c'était plus plus de la découverte
de l'exploration touché la texture
regarder commencé avec aussi des enfants
qui ont pu regarder mais je n'y a pas eu
énormément de dégustation en tant que
tel débat donc on personne n'a goûté je
n'ai pas goûté n'avait pas goûté non
mais pas goûté non plus d'autres choses
d'autres films également que l'on peut
souligner
par exemple bientôt dans vos assiettes
je crois c'est ça oui benoît ira donc le
film bientôt dans vos assiettes
c'est
c'est un petit peu une étude de
de tout ce qu'elle est tout ce qu'on
peut voir comme nouvelle nouveau
nouveaux éléments s'il est comme les ogm
et tout ce qui arrive dans nos assiettes
en fait comme les organismes
génétiquement modifiés qui sont depuis
un certain moment qu'on veut justement
banalisée dans la consommation
dans la consommation de tout le monde et
les
vraiment comment on
comment on apprécie cette phénomène
actuellement en fait quelle agriculture
pour demain c'est un peu ça y à travers
ce festival à vous interroger aussi la
population vous interrogez les pouvoirs
publics vous interrogé aussi sur quelle
agriculture vous allez proposer pour
demain d'ailleurs les 5 et 6 décembre la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
organise les assises de l'agriculture
est ce que vous comptez participer est
ce que vous comptez en russie donnez
votre avis sur sur sur quelles
articulations pour demain notamment pour
la martinique donc on n'a pas ce
réellement prévu d'y participer mais
c'est sûr que on est avec le festival on
élève un peu le débat
à tout le monde et on espère que toutes
les problématiques qu'on soulève et tous
les
tous les problèmes éthiques qu'on
soulève pourront être enrayée
l'or lors de ces assises alors 88 8
filles reviennent sur un peu sur les
films vivent dignement de sa terre ça
veut dire que nous il ya aussi vous
soulevez aussi le problème des
agriculteurs qui n'arrive pas qu'ils
sont qui sont des travailleurs pauvres
qui ont une terre mais qui ne vivent pas
de leur de leur agriculture de leur
travail
oui effectivement donc le vit le film
vivre dignement de satc se passe au
sénégal et c'est comment des
agriculteurs plutôt pauvre arrive à
subvenir à leurs besoins
à part des pratiques agroécologiques et
c'est le terme à la mode l'agroécologie
sinagot écologie effectivement et
c'est ça tourne autour de ce sujet là
lors les organisations paysannes et les
circuits courts
d'accord mais là rené corail je vous
remercie
excellente journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes et j'en ai ainsi bonne
journée
[Musique]